I think we'll see in September but I I
expect that a lot of people will show up
for this elections and we'll have
interesting results for United Russia
and I think this nominees idea of smart
election really works like he's he's
asking us to vote for anybody except
their ruling party and besides showing
up at elections I think people will show
up in the Straits and I was actually
really surprised by the moods of the
people that I've seen 27th of July I did
not expect it I was thinking that it
would be just a normal gathering near
the government building and I've seen
this so many of them in my life and all
of a sudden people just refuse to leave
and it's a boy in Moscow turned into a
big anti-government festival like
anti-government opinator which feels
really amazing it feels to me like 1968
in Paris and what did you think when you
heard that Novelli had fallen ill in
jail do you think he was poisoned
I felt it because because my ex-husband
was poisoned and he was poisoned much
more seriously actually but we didn't
know like how serious it is with Navalny
and we still don't know for sure because
there the court refused to let him go to
get proper communication in in real life
and he's not he's not really under
criminal investigation and he is pretty
seriously ill and they don't let him go
to make like really independent medical
care and it raises lots of questions
like why and I've seen it happening with
the situation of Peter Brazil of doctors
for trying to hide
is blood urine samples and I was trying
to track record down it was completely
impossible though members of family or
lawyers that they can get this samples
and we were writing letters to multiple
doctors offices and investigation
committee and police and nobody reacted
so basically they're the russian
government they were just trying to hide
everything that there is somehow
connected to peter's poisoning and right
now they're hiding nobody and your Maria
was was detained in the last
demonstration yeah is it she was just
sitting on the grass probably they know
who she is right the police I mean yeah
I don't think they knew they um yeah
it's just arrested everybody and the
craziest part about this arrest was like
they they would take here in a ring of
police and they would tell you you
should go away but they don't let you go
away because you're in the ring with
police and I told like you're in the
trap and I heard from many people that
it's really like close to public and
terrible feeling it was a really moving
moment when a church in Moscow helped to
hide protesters because they were
trapped in this ring and so they they
escaped to the church and there the head
of this church leader he I think he
commented even publicly about about this
event and he's just a normal Orthodox
priest was just interesting it feels
like you know like actually Virgin Mary
who asked to get rid of poison really
and listen to what we had to tell her
and so now we've been Orthodox Church
parts of it is another side but yeah
Masha was arrested just being a true
Blair it was like after 7 p.m. I think
so she was just been walking at this
anti-government festival all day long
and yeah she was arrested she ended up
in police department for three days
which is kind of the words because
police departments are not done for not
spending any time like longer than three
hours in them so sometimes they don't
feed you they didn't give you a place to
sleep and you literally have to sleep
those three days and in a cage and after
that she they brought him to court and
now she has to pay a fine for just
sitting on the grass for the end-of-line
is 150,000 troubles was just like $2,000
is it scary for you to go out to
demonstrations like that for some reason
no it was because I didn't know because
you you're ready for you're ready to be
arrested and you at the moment when you
accept did you can be arrested it's not
scary for you anymore and plus it it's
been happening with me so many times and
I know more or less what can happen and
you always hope that the worst will not
happen with you like the criminal case
which is unfortunately happening right
now not towards me but they opened a big
criminal case which will be like really
historic event in Moscow in Russia I
think it will be something like bullet
nur case in 2012 when dozens of people
have been arrested for years after that
demonstration and yeah do your two years
in your in that prison camp do they
still sit with you do you still have
nightmares about it does it come in yes
yeah I just
this may die so during them both prison
about being in prison again
and they were like oh will give you
parole I know
I have like only five months left I
would not be asking for a parole because
they wouldn't never give me pearl yeah
that's what this was my conversation my
dream today but today was not that
terrible because five months it's not
it's not a terrible time but like I I
know that it's a nightmare
when when it's about like ten years in
prison and when I'm in the court again
and for just nothing yeah and I'm facing
ten years do that that's pretty tough I
mean in prison they in your dream you
start to sink like how Hong Kong spent
is ten years because it's a good big
chunk of your life